wo ist justyna justyna ist beim pommes
laden wo ist justyna justyna ist beim
obst stand hallo liebe leute vor sechs
jahren haben wir bei easyjet ein video
veröffentlicht mit dem titel wo ist
justyna christina war damals 15
sie war eine austauschschülerin an der
schule wo wir gearbeitet haben und heute
ist sie tatsächlich ein teil von easy
languages nämlich die produzentin von
easy polnisch und justina wie ist es
damals zu diesem komischen video
gekommen
ja also es war ein diese schule und hat
diese geniale ist zu machen und ich
wusste damals nicht dass dieses video
sehr viel wird und kommentaren bekommen
will
und weil dieses video so populär war
machen wir heute noch mal ein remake von
diesem video und wir werden nochmal auf
die erfolgsfaktoren setzen justina an
komischen orten und justina sieht dabei
besonders glücklich aus christina freust
du dich schon mitzumachen
wir sehen los geht's
wo ist justyna justyna ist auf dem weg
zum buchladen wo es ina justina kommt
gerade aus dem buchladen wo ist justyna
justyna ist mit ihrem buch auf der
straße
es gibt einige präpositionen die werden
immer mit dem dativ gebildet und es gibt
einige positionen die werden immer mit
dem akkusativ gebildet außerdem gibt es
präpositionen die mit beiden fällen
gebildet werden können
im moment gucken wir uns die daten
präpositionen an justyna ist ab der
ersten minute in ihr neues buch vertieft
außer ihrem buch nimmt sie nichts mehr
wahr
hallo ist da wo ist justyna justina muss
von der straße gezogen werden
wo ist justyna jetzt justina steht
gegenüber der bank
wo ist justyna nach dem ersten kapitel
steht justina immer noch hier
das waren die dativ präpositionen die
meisten präpositionen antworten auf die
frage wo jetzt gucken wir uns die
akkusativ positionen an die meisten
akkusativ präpositionen antworten auf
die frage woher oder wohin
während die daten positionen meistens
einen ort oder einen zustand beschreiben
wir schreiben die akkusativ
präpositionen meistens einen ortswechsel
oder die veränderung eines zustandes
woher geht das thema justina geht durch
das geschäft
woher geht justina justina geht um den
mülleimer herum
wohin geht justina justina geht bis zur
treppe wohin läuft sistina justina läuft
gegen die treppe wo hingeht justina
dieses thema geht ohne ihr buch weiter
was macht justine jetzt sie sammelt geld
für ein neues buch als nächstes gucken
wir uns die wechsel präpositionen an die
wechsel präpositionen werden mit einem
da tief gebildet wenn sie einen ort oder
einen unveränderten zustand beschreiben
sie werden aber mit dem aggressiv
gebildet wenn sie eine bewegung oder
eine veränderung eines zustandes
beschreiben
wohin geht justina justina geht in das
geschäft
wo ist justyna justyna ist im geschäft
und liest was macht justina justina
lehnt sich an das haus wo ist justyna
justina lehnt am haus wo hingeht justina
justina stellt sich neben einen
tanzenden man wo steht justina jetzt
justina steht neben einem tanzenden man
übrigens wenn ihr mehr lernen wollt zu
diesem thema dann schaut doch mal bei
unserer app ceiling vorbei
dort findet ihr mehr informationen und
mehr beispiele zu den deutschen
positionen und außerdem viele nützliche
übungen
wohin geht justina jetzt justina stellt
sich hinter einen baum wo ist justyna
jetzt justina steht hinter einem baum
wohin geht es tina justina stellt sich
auf die bank wo ist justyna christina
ist auf der bank wohin geht justina
justina stellt sich über mich wo ist
dieses thema ist ina ist über mir
justina stellt sich unter den baum wo
ist das team ihres thema ist unter dem
baum
christina stellt sich zwischen die bäume
wo ist justyna justyna ist zwischen den
bäumen
wohin geht justina die justina geht vor
den einkaufswagen wo ist justyna justyna
ist vor dem einkaufswagen
hier ist thema dieses buch scheint aber
wirklich interessant gewesen zu sein
ja ja das hat es mit gegeben und es
heißt spirituelle meister
ok jetzt verstehe ich so einiges und
wenn ihr auch ein meister werden wollt
der deutschen sprache dann schaut doch
mal bei unserer app siedlung vorbei
dort findet ihr nämlich viele weitere
nützliche übungen zum thema deutsche
präpositionen und man sagt ja auf
deutsch übung macht den meister
und wenn ihr lust hat dann schaut auch
mal bei ist sie nach vorbei
nämlich der host von easy paulisch und
weil sie politisch gibt es demnächst
auch ein ähnliches video über
präpositionen danke dass du da warst ina
lenke euch und übrigens bei easy spanish
auch da könnt ihr auch noch mal verweise
und links sind hier unten danke bis zu
sehen
bis nächste woche
[Musik]